are you in
Welcome back everyone this will be my new flash
movie video a lot of people asking what's going
on with dc movies in general i'll explain what's
up because they made a couple big announcements
they also made a big announcement about their
plans for a crisis on infinite earth's movie in
the dceu like a big end capper like an avengers
infinity war avengers end game type of situation
for the dc eu so i'll explain what's going on with
that what their plans are and how they've changed
and it looks like they've found who their new
version of kevin feige is going to be in charge
of all the dc movies going forward like
that 10-year plan that they announced
so i will explain who that is but if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing more dc videos like even
though it's a bloodbath at dc right now with shows
and movies getting cancelled left and right they
are still making some of the big budget hbo shows
and obviously some of the movies are still being
planned i'll explain what survived during the
video too peacemaker season 2 is gonna be like the
next big hbo dc show that they do the batman hbo
series will be after that and they just revealed
that they are still making that green lantern hbo
series but it's not supposed to release till
2024 but the big news you probably saw on your
fees the past couple days is warner brothers plan
for the flash movie ezra miller how their grand
overarching plan for the next big justice league
movie has changed just a little with all the crazy
behind-the-scenes stuff that's been happening all
over the place like dc has changed fundamentally
they have this new 10-year plan but also on the
side you have all this crazy ezra miller stuff
going on in real life first things first though
dc and warner brothers currently planning on three
different contingency plans for the flash movie
they either do nothing and hope that all this
craziness blows over by the time the movie's
released next summer and have ezra miller just
issue like a public apology and kind of put him
in a closet where he can't cause more problems
until the movie is finished being released option
two and i think this is the best option if things
do get worse which let's not kid ourselves they're
probably gonna get a little bit worse they'll just
kind of delete him from all their press plans for
the movie like he'll still be in the movie and
i'll explain why because there's some twists with
the way they're using ezra miller in the villain
of the flash movie he'll still issue some sort
of public statement but like they won't use him
during any of their press and they'll shoot a
new post credit scene where at the end of the
movie he'll basically pass the baton to like a
new version of flash so like ezra miller will
basically be out as dceu flash the reason i think
this is the best option is just because it allows
them to sort of explain canonically what happened
to his version of the flash why he's not around in
any more future films and also give them a chance
to start fresh with like a totally different actor
they won't bring all this extra baggage with him
like we just want to watch a really cool movie we
don't want to deal with all this crazy real life
stuff that's going on or their third option and
this is like the nuclear option if things get
really really bad which they always could worst
case scenario they'll just cancel the whole flash
movie and never release it like they're doing
with the batgirl movie like the only way we're
gonna see the batgirl movie now is if somebody
steals it from warner brothers because of this
weird tax loophole they're using there's these
special tax rules that they'll wind up having
to pay way more money if they do release it in
some fashion so like they literally have to just
put it on a shelf in a deep dark hole somewhere
the problem with them canceling the flash movie
outright like never releasing it is that it cost
them already about 300 million dollars which is
way more than the batgirl movie which cost like
90 million dollars still a ton of money but a 90
million dollar pill is a little easier for them
to swallow as like a giant corporation than a 300
million dollar pill so right now i would just plan
for them to get rid of ezra miller at the end
of the flash movie like something will happen
to him and the baton will be passed to either like
a version of wally west or like another multiverse
version of barry allen i would be fine with either
eventuality the reason why they can't just reshoot
all of ezra miller scenes with a different actor
or like digitally replace his face is because he's
in the movie twice and he's in most of the scenes
because there's like a multiverse version of ezra
miller that you see in the background of all
these shots you notice the multiverse version
of the character is wearing a flash suit that's
like cobbled together from an old batman suit of
michael keaton's and the flash symbol on it looks
very similar to the reverse flash symbol that's
because the real villain of the flash movie is
supposed to be this multiverse version like he'll
be a dark version of baryon so it'll be like the
good dc eu version of barry allen against the dark
version of barry allen from this other universe
from michael keaton batman universe so essentially
they'd have to completely remake the movie from
the ground up twice i also just did a video about
how they're going to end the flash tv show after
the next season like season 9 will be the last
season so grant gustin will basically be done as
the tv show version the flash after that in the
very last episode is going to air right before
the flash movie comes out so a lot of people are
like putting the dots together saying like wait
a minute if you're going to end the flash tv show
and then like right after that the flash movie's
going to happen why don't you just shoot a post
credit scene where grant gustin becomes the movie
flash because they already crossed over in crisis
on infinite earth so sorority cannon that grant
gustin is connected to the dceu i'm also the flash
the also the what it's complicated even though
that would be a cool twist the reason why i don't
think they're gonna do it is because grant gustin
has probably just been playing the flash for so
long that he probably wants to take a break in
warner brothers in dc probably want an actor who
can be their version of the flash in a bunch of
movies for like the next 10 years so grant gustin
probably doesn't want to sign on for like another
10 years of being the flash in a bunch of stuff
all the time but i do hope that they have sort of
like a small grant gustin cameo scene during the
movie it would be weird if they don't have a grand
gustin cameo scene but i also just did a video for
the aquaman 2 post credit scene first look because
they just brought ben affleck's batman back for
aquaman 2 to shoot a completely different post
credit scene where aquaman was going to meet a
version of batman but in the original version
it was supposed to be michael keaton's batman
because originally they were going to release
aquaman 2 after the flash movie so like you
were going to have met michael keaton's batman
he was going to be part of the dceu multiverse
then later in the timeline aquaman 2 would come
out and aquaman would meet that new michael keaton
batman but because they changed the release order
the movies and now aquaman 2 is coming out before
the flash movie most audiences were confused why
it was michael keaton's batman like wait what's he
doing here where'd he come from so dc just had to
bring in ben affleck's batman for continuity sake
just to explain the crisis on infinite
earth's movie that they also announced
so originally but before all this big dc buyout
before everything changed behind the scenes before
they announced their brand new 10-year plan for
the dc movies originally they were going to use
the flash movie to set up a crisis on infinite
earth's movie and it was going to be like their
version of avengers infinity war and avengers end
game like a future justice league crossover where
all the big dc movie characters cross over with
each other because they wouldn't have wanted to
copy the dc tv version of crisis on inventors
it would have been a vastly different plot a
lot of the characters would look very different
obviously what's changed now is it sounds like
they've completely changed their plan for all
these future movies they still want to do more
justice league films but it sounds like now the
next justice league film will be more like justice
league versus black adam and more of their plans
are turning on the rocks black adam character
and what's going on with some of these newer
characters especially the more popular ones like
superman like superman is a big part of their
future plans they still might wind up doing a
crisis on infinite earth's movie at the end of all
this like at the end of 10 years but like i said
because they said it's a 10 year plan it's not
going to happen for a long time the funny thing
about that change now too is if they do end with
a crisis on infinite earth's movie in 10 years
it'll be a very similar situation to what marvel
is doing with avengers 5 kang dynasty in avengers
6 secret wars big multiverse phase also like
multiverse is the operative word in all these
big story universes right now but like literally
crisis on infinite earths is where they collapse
the multiverse like they destroy a bunch of
universes that's kind of what they're doing
during avengers 5 kang dynasty also part of their
new movie plan is to make all the movies a little
more interconnected and cross over way more the
only dc movies that are immune to this right now
are the matt reeves batman movies with barbara
pattinson they don't have to cross over right
now according to them in the joker 2 movie
with joaquin phoenix there are no plans to
cross that over with the other versions of
batman at this point but the new kevin feige
figure that it sounds like is going to run dc
movies or at least their top candidate right now
is greg berlanti who most people will remember
from all the dc tv stuff if you don't know much
about greg berlanti outside of the dc tv stuff
he basically has his own tv and movie company a
little while ago he had 10 different shows all
airing at the same time while they were also
releasing multiple movies at the same time so he's
like one of the few people in hollywood that can
handle like a giant machine like this and has
a ton of experience in just making tv shows and
movies outright he's not their only candidate it
just sounds like he's one of their top candidates
he's also currently making some of the big budget
hbo tv series right now like the green lantern hbo
series is a great berlanti series my other guess
would have been that they would have formed like
a smaller committee and on that committee they
would have put people like greg berlanti who have
experience in actually like making and releasing
tv shows and movies and people like jim lee who
just like really understand the characters and
have a deep connection to the comic side but
hopefully that explains what's going on with the
flash movie and what dc's current plans are right
now now it's a developing situation so like by
the end of this year we'll have more information
about what their grand plan is but currently like
the movies that you know about right now like the
flash movie aquaman 2 the batman sequels the joker
sequel all that stuff is still coming out most
of the stuff that's been canceled are tv shows
primarily and it's all the stuff that came before
that was not planned as like big budget hbo series
that connected to the movies like the arrow versus
kind of dying with the flash because superman and
lois just explained that they're taking place in
an alternate universe it's not like the arrowverse
version of superman don't worry though there will
be big budget dc shows coming to hbo in the future
though like we will have dc episodes to talk about
but it'll just be a bunch of the brand new
stuff everyone click here for that aquaman 2
batman first look video and click here for
my she-hulk world war hulk trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!